[موسيقى]
هذه اذا المشاهدين صور مباشره من سيدني
احتفالا بدخول العام الجديد
2003 و20 الترقب الان والعد التنازلي
لنهايه سنه 20022 وبدايه السنه الجديده
2023 كل عام وانتم بخير
[موسيقى]
كل عام وانتم بخير اهلا بكم الى نشره
الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها
ابرز اخباره وملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه
ابرز عناوين اليوم
غارات الروسيه المكثفه على كيف وميكو لايف
تتسبب بخسائر كبيره في منشات طاقه كهرباء
عمده
يؤكد وقوع انفجارات ويحذر السكان من ضربات
صاروخيه جديده
ايران انترناشونال تقول بان القوات الامن
الايرانيه هاجمت متظاهرين وسط سوق
بالعاصمه طهران
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
نستعرض معكم ابرز الاحداث السياسيه
والاقتصاديه في السعوديه والخليج خلال
حياكم الله اعلن عمده كيف مقتل شخص واصابه
اخرين جرائم في جارات دوات في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف بعد غراتان صاروخيه
الروسيه
وقالت رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان الفندق في كيف
تضرر جراء الانفجارات فيما اظهرت صور
متداوله تصاعد اعمده الدخان بالقرب من
محطه كهرباء في العاصمه الاوكرانيه بدوره
قال نائب في البرلمان الاوكراني ان
امدادات الطاقه توقفت مؤقتا في كيف بعد
الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه بالتزامن مع
ذلك اكد عمده ميكو لايف جنوبي البلاد وقوع
انفجارات كما حذر سكان من ضربات صاروخيه
جديده
اصدر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قرارا
لانشاء نظام لتدريب المتخصصين في تطوير
وانتاج المسيارات واوضح الكريم في بيان ان
بوتين امر بانشاء الى جنه حكوميه لتطوير
المسيرات برئاسه نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
اندريه سوف
اذا زود صفرات الانذار في مناطق اوكرانيه
متفرقه في وقت في وقت اكد فيه وزير الدفاع
الروسي حتميه انتصار قوات بلاده في
العمليه العسكريه باوكرانيا قبل ذلك افادت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه بشان القوات
الروسيه ضربات صاروخيه مكثفه لاستنزاف
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه كلها سبعه الى
عشره ايام منذ اكتوبر الماضي
كشفت ايران انترناشونال من خلال مقاطع
فيديو حصلت عليها استخدام قوات الامن
الايرانيه العنف ضد محتاجين تجمعوا
للتظاهر في سوق كلوبندق في العاصمه طهران
واعتقلت قوات الامن عددا من المحتاجين
بشكل تعسفي بحجه التحريض على العنف ردد
المتظاهرون في سوق طهران المركزي هتافات
الموت لخامنئي والموت للديكتاتور
[موسيقى]
لم يكن للاسف عام 2022 عاما هادئا على
مستوى العالم حيث شكلت الازمه الاوكرانيه
واسعار الطاقه ومخاوف الركود الاقتصادي
عناوينه العريضه هذه الازمات والمخاوف
العالميه حولت منطقه الخليج والسعوديه
تحديدا الى وجهه لم تتوقف عن استقبال
زعماء الدول الكبرى حيث جرت مشاورات
ثنائيه واخرى خليجيه وعربيه مشتركه اما
على الصعيد الاقتصادي في السعوديه فقد شهد
العام اعلانات متتاليه الاستراتيجيات
ومشاريع اقتصاديه ضمن رؤيه 20 30 اسواق
الاسهم العالميه والخليجيه من ضمنها لم
يكن عام 2022 عاما مبتسما لها السوق
السعودي وهو الاكبر في المنطقه سجل اول
خساره سنويه له منذ سبع سنوات
والى الكويت حيث تشهد او حيث شهد هذا
العام تشكيل حكومه جديده وحل وانتخابات
برلمانيه بالاضافه الى جدل وسجالات حول ما
عرف بوثيقه القيم ولجنه الظواهر هذه
الملفات مشاهدينا وغيرها نناقشها اليوم في
نشره الرابعه مع عدد من المختصين
والمحللين
[موسيقى]
اذا استقبلت السعوديه خلال عام 2022 عدا
كبيرا من زعماء وقاده العالم لمناقشه
الملفات الثنائيه والتطورات العالميه
المتسارعه بالاضافه الى قسمين احدهما في
جده بحضور الرئيس الامريكي والاخرى في
الرياض بمشاركه الرئيس الصيني والدول
الخليجيه والعربيه نتابعوا ابرزت الكزيره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من جده دكتور عبد العزيز بن
صقر رئيس مركز الخليج للابحاث الدكتور عبد
العزيز مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض جمله من الاحداث السياسيه هذا
العام في السعوديه والخليج السعوديه
بدورها جماعه الخليج والعرب في طاولتين مع
قطبي النظام الدولي امريكا والصين في 2022
ما الذي تحقق منها هل اختارت السعوديه
الجنوح مع احد القطبي
اولا مساء الخير لك استاذ نايف ولكل
مشاهدينا العربيه في كل مكان ونتمنى ان
يكون عام 2023 عام خير وبركه اسود فيه
الامن والسلامه والازدهار لشعوب العالم
الحقيقه زياره القاده المهمين سواء الرئيس
الامريكي في قمه جده والرئيس الصيني في
قمه الرياضه والزعماء الذين توادوا عن
المملكه خلال عام 2022 هو تاكيد لدور
المملكه الاساسي
ودورها القيادي في المنطقه ليس فقط على
مستوى اهميه العلاقه الثنائيه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولكن دور المملكه
القيادي فيما في منظومه دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وايضا في المنظومه العربيه والشرق
الاوسطيه وايضا يمكن حكم عضيتها في مجموعه
العشرين الدوليه فهذا تاكيد على اهميه
المملكه ودورها التوقيت جاء بعد مجموعه من
القضايا يعني ما كنا نخرج من ازمه يعني
كورونا والجائحه عام 2021 حتى بدانا عام
22 بالازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه وعوده الى
مفهوم الحرب البارده وارتفاع في اسعار
النفط
ومجموعه القضايا هذه القلمتين التي حدثت
جاءت لتؤكد ان السعوديه تفهم وتعي
مسؤوليتها الاقليميه والدوليه تعي اهميه
هذه العلاقه بنسبه لها مع القطبين الكبيره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمال المملكه
لها من علاقه تاريخيه قديمه
جدا هي لا ترى ان احد منهم بديلا للاخر
ولذلك حافظت على علاقه متوازنه مع كافه
الاطراف حافظت على علاقات المتوازنه
والمهمه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وحافظه ايضا على علاقه اقتصاديه القويه مع
الصين طيب دكتور تخفيض انتاج في همم قبل
نوفمبر كان قرارا الاقتصاد وشغل السياسه
كذلك كان قرارا بحثا كما قالت مجموعه اوبك
بلس في مقدماتها طبعا من السعوديه لكن هو
اخذ ابعادها سياسيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما تعلم التي اعتبرته عديا
اعتبرته كذلك احيازا لروسيا كيف تنظر
لنتائجه السياسيه حتى الان والتعامل
السعودي مع هذا الموقع
المملكه قررت ان تتعامل من منطلق مصالحها
واقرار اوبك بلس وكان قرار منطلقه توافقي
وفني بحث ولذلك ادعى الكثير انه سوف يؤثر
على الاقتصاد الامريكي وعلى وضع
الانتخابات ولكنه لم يؤثر والدليل انه بعد
قرار اوبلاس انخفضت اسعار النفط ولم ترتفع
فلم يؤثر هذا على وضع الانتخابات الداخليه
ورفضت المملكه ان يستخدم موضوع اوبلاس
كذريعه وحجه في قضايا انتخابيه داخليه
للولايات المتحده ال- الامريكيون يقررون
من يختارون من الاحزاب التي يريدون لها
غالبيه في الكونجرس او في الحكم وهذا قرار
داخلي امريكي فلذلك لم تتاثر المملكه
بالضغوط الامريكيه والرغبات التي كانت
موجوده
حافظت على قرارها
واكدت على سيادتها في ما يتعلق بهذا
القرار وكان قرارا جماعيا توافقيا بين كل
الاطراف
ناتج عنه النتيجه الايجابيه التي نراها ان
المملكه استطاعت ترسل رساله للعالم لم نعد
تلك الدوله التي تقبل الاملاءات ولكن
الدوله ذات سياده نتعامل من منطلق مصالحنا
ومصالح الدول التي لها يعني مصالح معنى
مهمه دون ان نخضع لاي ضغوط ايا كانت من
منطلق المصالح همم الدكتور ايضا
الموقف الخليجي الموقف السعودي ايضا
تحديدا في الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه بقيه
موقفا على همم الحياه لم ياخذ او لم يجنح
الى احد طرفي همم النزاع برايك هذا الموقف
ثابت الدكتور
هو موقف متوازن وليس موقف حياتي التوازن
في اننا نعي ثوابت ثوابت ان اوكرانيا دوله
عضو في الامم المتحده لا يمكن ان نقبل ان
يتم احتلالها بالقوه واستخدام القوه وزير
خارجيه السعودي اكد على وحده اوكرانيا
وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه نعي تماما اهميه
ان يسود الامن والسلامه هذه قضيه اوروبيه
في منطقتهم علاقتنا مع روسيا لم تتاثر لان
هذا هذا خلاف فيما بين دولتين يحل داخل
الامم المتحده ويحل واكدنا على قضيه البعد
السلمي في الحلول والسياسي ساهمنا في
ساهمت المملكه في موضوع اطلاق سراح
الرهائن في البعد الانساني قدمت مساعدات
انسانيه مهمه لاوكرانيا بقدر ما هو مطلوب
لكنه لم تتدخل من اي نقطه هي لان ترفض
المملكه العوده الى مفهوم الحرب البارده
الذي اراد البعض ان يعود اليه
كانت محورا على موقف توازن ممكن متوازن
مهم وهذا الموقف المتوازي المهم مثلنا مثل
دوله زي الهند وزي تركيا بالرغم ان تركيا
عضو في حلف الناتو ولكن ايضا هم حافظوا
على التوازن قدمت المملكه ما تستطيع ان
تقدم في هذا الجانب لانه يعني ابقت ولذلك
هذه النقطه التي يقول ان حافظه المملكه
على تواجد تندفع للجانب الامريكي في قبول
الضغط على روسيا او باي مساهمات هي ابقت
العلاقه جيده مع روسيا هي لم تقبل احتلال
الارض بالقوه والصراع الذي يحدث في
اوكرانيا وقدمت المساعدات الانسانيه همم
فاستطاعت ان توجد هذه التوازنيه في
العلاقات والتي لم تكون في السابق موجوده
بهذا الشكل طيب عديد الزعماء كانت
السعوديه قبله لهم في همم الايام الماضيه
خلال هذا العام والتقى تحديدا لولي العهد
السعودي رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن
سلمان اسال عن دور القيادي الثقل السياسي
لهذه الشخصيه لهذا العام دكتور
هو اعتراف بدور المملكه القيادي هو اعتراف
بدور سمو ولي عهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
وقيادته الحكيمه هو ايضا اعتراف باهميه
المملكه ولذلك حينما تكون زيارات شخصيه
فهذه الدول لها متطلبات ولها طلبات تريد
باللقاء الشخصي ان تقدم طلباتا مباشره
المملكه وان تحاول الحصول على بعض
التنازلات نحن راينا ذلك حينما دار
المستشار الالماني او بعض الرؤساء الذين
زاروا من دون مختلفه مثل الجنوب افريقيا
وخلافه ولكن المملكه دائما تعاملتنا منطلق
مصالحها الاساسيه والوطنيه التي يجب ان
تسود في كل الحالات قد تقدر هذه العلاقات
الثنائيه وتهتم بها ولها مكانات وتقديرها
ولكن هذا اعتراف دولي من كل القيادات
العالميه بان الدور هو دور المملكه هي
الدوله المؤثره خليجيا وعربيا وشرق
اوساطيا واذا اقتنعت المملكه بالموقف
السياسي المطلوب فيتستطيع ان تقنع الاخرين
بهذا الموقع الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر
رئيس مركز ابحاث الخليج اللامحات شكرا
جزيلا لك
شهد العام 2022 احداثا سياسيه ساخنه
بالكويت فمن حل مجلس الامه الى استقاله
حكومتين وصولا الى انتخابات برلمانيه
جديده نجحت حتى الان في تهدئه التصادم بين
السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه على رغم ما
اثارت من جدل على مستوى الشارع بسبب ما
عرف بوثيقه القيم ولجنه الظواهر السلبيه
لم يكن عام 2022 هادئا بالنسبه للكويت
وخاصه سياسيه على النطاق الحكومي جاءت
استقاله الحكومه التي تشكلت في ديسمبر
2021 برئاسه الشيخ صباح الخالد في مايو
برئاسه الشيخ احمد النواف في يوليو لهذا
العام لكن سرعان استقاله الحكومه وصدر
مرسوم اميري باعاده تشكيلها في اغسطس بنفس
العام
السلطه التشريعيه من جهه اخرى والمتمثله
بمجلس الامه واجهه بدورها رائحه تصادم مع
السلطه التنفيذيه واستجوابات ساهمت في
زياده التوتر بين السلطتين لينتج عنها
اعلان حلل لمجلس الامه في يونيو الامر
الذي قبل بترحيب من بعض النواب ليتم الحلف
في اغسطس من العام
الجاريا والدعوه الى انتخابات عامه وفقا
للاجراءات والمواعيد والضوابط الدستوريه
وقبل انتخابات مجلس 2022 الذي عقدت في
سبتمبر اعلن نحو 15 مرشحا عن عدد من
اولوياتها في حال وصولهم لقبه عبد الله
السالم وثيقه القيام كانت الابرز من
انقسام الناخبين ما بين مؤيد ومعارض
فالمؤيدون راو بانها تحافظوا على مبادئ
المجتمع الكويتي بينما راى المعارضون بان
لا حاجه لوصايه من مرشحين يفترض بهم
مراقبته اداء الحكومه وفي ما يتعلق
بالانشطه الاجتماعيه شهد العام 2022 منع
بعض الفتيات والشباب من ممارسه الرياضه
معا ورفض بعض النواب ممارسه الفتيات
لليوجا باثاره الجدل حول حقيقتها وتاريخها
الديني وما ان تشكل مجلس الامه تشكلت معه
لجان جديده كلجنه ظواهر السلبيه التي تسعى
اليوم الى فصل الطلاب عن الطالبات في
مباني الجامعه ما جعل شارع الكويتيه
يتساءل عن الغايه من انشائي هذه الجنه
العلاقه بين السلطتين ما زالت طبابيه فراغ
من الاحداث السريعه بينهما خلال عام فهي
مستمره حتى الان دون صدام يذكر
شهد المتروك العربي العربيه
السابق دكتور سعد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض الدكتور بدايه
كيف تقرا حصاد سنه 2022 من السياسي في
الكويت
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه عام 22 اعتقد بان عام مفصل في عده
مفاصل حدثت في همم طبعا تعهد السلطه لاول
مره
واعترافها ضمني بانها كانت تتدخل في
الانتخابات السابقه وتعهدها هذه المره
بعدم التدخل وهو ما شهد له الجميع ويسجل
لها الحقيقه همم ولذلك جاءت انتخابات الى
درجه عاليه من النزاهه رغم انني مثلا
متحفظ على بقاء يعني الدوائر على ما هي
عليه صوره واحد ومعي الكثيرين من
المتحفظين الحقيقه همم لكن هذه الانتخابات
خلينا نقول الحكومه السابقه لرئيسها
وازاحه البرلمان السابق او معظم اعضاء
البرلمان السابق
وفي خطاب اسمه ولي العهد خطاب الامير الذي
القاسم العهد في 22 يونيو قال او القى
باللوم على تلك العلاقه المتوتره بين
السلطتين على الرئاستين رئاسه البرلمان
ورئاسه الحكم
السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعه مع
التشريعيه طبعا مع بعضهما البعض بعد حل
البرلمان بعد تغيير الحكومه ايضا لا مرتين
قدوم رئيس حكومه جديده
صحيح ولذلك انا اعتقد ان لا زالت هذه
الحكومه حتى بعد تغير رئيسها وتشكيلها
جديد وتشكيلها الاخير يعني تعاني من مطبات
كثيره ليس سرا بان وزير الدفاع قد قدم
استقالته وبانه اجازه مفتوحه لكن الان
يعني لم يعلن قبلها رسميا ولكن هذا مؤشر
الى مدى الازمه التي تعيش الحكومه ومؤشر
الى المطبات القادمه التي سوف تقع بها
الحكومه في مواجهه البرلمان ممتاز همم
تحدثت عن نقطه مهمه قبل قليل همم يعني في
ثنايا حديثك تتحدثون عن غياب شخصيه الرئيس
السابق للبرلمان همم مجلس الامه الكويتيه
مرزوق الغانم عن المشهد البرلماني هلا
كمان اي تعليق على غياب هذه الشخصيه كيف
انعكس غيابها ايضا حتى على المشهد
البرلماني والسياسي في الكويت
الاجابه على هذا السؤال في العام 23
بصراحه في العام القادم بمعنى اذا استطاع
هذا البرلمان ان يحرك الملفات الاساسيه
التي تمس حياه الانسان من رفع مستوى
المعيشه ووقف ارتفاع الاسعار والتضخم
ومحاربه الفساد وحل اشكاليه الجنسيه
والبدون والدوائر الانتقاليه وصوت الواحد
وحق الانسان في اللجوء الى المحكمه في
حاله نزع الجنسيه منه اعتقد بان اذا
استطاعوا ان يحققه ذلك في هذا البرلمان
سيقول الناس اي شفت شلون هذا من بسبب
مرزوق الغانم ومجلسهم لكن اذا لم يتحقق
هذا الشيء ايضا سيكون الناس هذا معناه ان
انتم خصومتكم مع مرزوق الغانم كان شخصيا
والدليل ان انت ما سويتوا شيء مثلكم مرزوق
الغانم وبالتالي انا اقول ان الاجابه تكون
في الايام القادمه وان كنت غير متفائل همم
في الفترات الاخيره غير متفائله يا دكتور
سعد بالوضع القادم في الكويت ده ينسحب على
2013 كمان افهم الان حتى
ان
ني صحيح ان يعني في همم يعني تغيرات خلينا
نقول جذريه في مح
اسبيه للفساد لكنها لا نرى يعني
استراتيجيه شامله نحن نرى مثلا على سبيل
المثال تغيير في القيادات واستقالات في
القيادات طيب هل هذا يعني القيادات هذه مو
بالضروره كلها تحتهم حولها شبهات يعني همم
كثير منهم الحقيقه وبعضهم يعني يشهد لها
بالنزاهه وبالعمل الجاد واعطي همم قراءات
من اجل التقاعد المبكر وذهب وقدموا
استقالاتهم طيب ما هو البديل هل انت يعني
السؤال الذي يطرح لنا الناس يعني هل نحن
فعلا ندخل بعهد جديد اتمنى ان انا لا تقول
لفرقه جديده بدلا من الفرق القديمه هذا هو
السؤال الذي يطرحه الناس ويتردد على سنتين
الان
هل يمكن ان تستمر هذه العلاقه بين المجلس
والحكم انا ما اعتقد بان هذا الشيء سيتم
لان الاليات التي كان يتم بها وادوات
الصدام التي كانت تحدث في الماضي لا زالت
قائمه وعليه فاننا لا نستطيع ان نجرب
المجرب ونعتقد باننا يمكن ان نخرج بنتيجه
دكتور اسلام السياسي لازال نشيطا في
الكويت وثيقه القيم مثلا اخذت حيزا كبيرا
من الجده بين الشدو في المجتمع الكويتي
وانا عكس ذلك ربما ايضا على الاراء في
موقع التواصل الاجتماعي كذلك ايضا حتى
لجنه الظواهر
السلبيه كيف تقيم هذا الوضع كيف تقيم نشاط
الاسلام السياسي في الكويت في هذا العام
شوف يعني خلنا نتكلم بعموميه وبعدين ادخل
لك في الشان الكويتيه اريني في هذا العالم
اييي يعني ديمقراطيه يساهم فيها الاسلام
السياسي بعمليه سلسه
متوائمه ومتوافقه لا يوجد
لا في العراق ولا في ايران ولا في لبنان
ولا في غزه ولا في تونس ولا في اي مكان
وبالتالي انت لازم تكون واقعي مع نفسك
يعني الاسلام السياسي هو يحمل فكر مناقب
تماما له شيء في الدستور وتعايش وحريه
وتبادل سلطه لانه يريد ان يقيم دوله دينيه
بمفهومه هو طبعا الاجسام السياسي بفرعيه
الاسلام السياسي استني يريد اقامه الخلافه
والاسلام السياسي الشيعي يريد اقامه دوله
الولايه او التبعيه لدوله الولايه هذا
واحد اثنين في
موضوع ظواهر السلبيه
هي انتخابات ليش
تحمسين يقول لهم حنا ترا ما احنا مشاركين
الديمقراطيه والانتخابات علشان الكراسي لا
هو من اجل يعني لوجه الله ومن اجل ان نقيم
حدود الله ومن اجل كذا كذا سبقنا قدمه مثل
هذا الموضوع الى يعني رقم الدستوريه وقالت
المحكمه الدستوريه بانني لا نستطيع ان
نقدم احكاما ما لم تحدد لي ما هي الظواهر
السلبيه وبالتالي يسقط هذا المفهوم لكن
هذا للاستهلاك طبعا ولل يعني
البساطه والناس الطيبين اعتقادا منهم بان
ما في ديمقراطيه في العالم ولا في برلمان
بالعالم يحاول التضييق على حريات الناس
البرلمانات في العالم تحاول دائما ان توسع
الحريات الناس وليس حتى ما ينص عليها
الدستور الكويتي توسيع الحريات وليس تضيقه
همم دكتور سعد انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر ما
تبقى هذه الكثير من الوقت همم شكرا لك من
الكويت او من اسبانيا الينا الدكتور سعد
من طفل وزير الاعلام الكويت السابق
حياكم الله من جديد شهد الاقتصاد السعودي
مشاهدينا خلال العام الجاريه 2022
اطلاقه عدد من الاستراتيجيات التي تهدف
لتحقيق رؤيه السعوديه 2030 كما شهد العام
اعلانا العديد من المشاريع والشركات ايضا
في عدد من المدن السعوديه نتابعوا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الجبال الكاتب الاقتصاديه
السعوديه فضل مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه
الاولى
ما الذي يمكن التقاطه من اداء الاقتصاد
السعودي هذا العام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يمكن التقاط ان
الاصلاحات
الهيكليه في الاقتصاد والاصلاحات الماليه
بدات تعطي ثمارها بشكل اكبر اييييه واضح
ان القياده السعوديه اصبحت اكثر تحكما في
الاقتصاد وفي الجانب المالي خاصه وان
النتائج التي نراها اليوم كانت ايجابيه
عندما نتحدث عن تجاوز حجم الاقتصاد
السعودي تريليون دولار لاول مره فهذا امر
غايه في الاهميه
ويجعلنا قريبين جدا من تحقيق هدف رؤيه
المملكه 2030 في ما يتعلق بحجم الاقتصاد
السعودي ايضا عندما تحقق الميزانيه العامه
فائضا ب 102 مليار همم ريال همم بعد اكثر
من تسع سنوات من الحجوزات هذا يؤكد بانه
هناك اصلاح تم تنفيذها والتنفيدها ونتائج
ايجابيه تم تحقيقها ايضا في الجانب الاخر
اعتقد ان تحقيق التوازن المالي بات امرا
مهما كان من الم همم ان يكون موعد تحقيق
التوازن المالي هو 20 23 فالحمد لله انه
تحقق في العام 20 22 وبالتالي الحكومه
اليوم متقدمه على الاهداف التي رسمتها لها
رؤيه المملكه من 20 30 بجانب مهم اذا سمحت
لي فيما يتعلق بالبطاله وانا ركز على هذا
الجانب اقل معدل بطاله خلال 20 سنه وصل
الى 9.7 وهذا مؤشر ايجابي على ان سنصل الى
7% في 2030 باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى تفضل
ماذا عن مراحل الانجاز ايضا كذلك بالنسبه
للمشروعات
التنمويه بالنسبه للمشروعات الخمس الكبرى
همم ايضا اسال كذلك عن المشروع الاكبر
والاهم الذي اعلن هذا العام في اليوم وهو
ده العين
طبعا كما نعلم ان هناك اكثر من مشروع من
المشروعات الكبرى على سبيل المثال ليوم
الكبرى و ايضا البحر الاحمر مشروع البحر
الاحمر مشروع القديه كل هذه المشروعات
كبرى داخل هذه المشاريع مشروعات اصغر ايضا
تتشكل من خلالها هذه المشروعات الكبرى
واشرت انت الى ذا لاين الذي اطلقه سمو ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وهي المدينه
الذكيه التي ستؤسس من الصفر همم
الاصطناعي والذكاء التقني وبالتالي وخفض
ايضا معدلات همم
التلوث بل ان نتعامل مع مدينه يفترض ان
يكون مخرجاتها صفر في جانب تلوث البيئه
هذه المدينه تحت ظل انشطه كثيره من ضمنها
الذكاء الاصطناعي الاقتصادي السياحي
الترفيه انه جسدي وكل هذه الامور مرتين
تكنولوجيا الحديثه انا اعتقد انها هذه هي
مدينه المستقبل خاصه انها المدينه الاولى
التي نفذ في العالم وبالتالي المملكه
ستكون قائده في هذا القطاع خاصه وانها
ستنشئ في نيوم وبالتالي سيكون هناك تكامل
في المشروعات هناك ايضا المشروعات اخرى
مراحل اخرى في القديه على سبيل المثال
المرحله الاولى في 20 23 وهذا امر مبشر
بالخير ايضا الاحمر هناك بعض الجزر التي
تم او شكل او شركه الحكومه على انجازها
وهذا ايضا غايه في الاهميه ومن ضمنها ايضا
جزيره سنداله التي تم الاعلان عنها مؤخرا
وهذه السياحه الفاخره في العالم ستكون
ستقطب تدفقات همم استثماريه اضافيه
فضل العلم
لم يكن العام 2022 عاما ايجابيا للاسواق
العالميه نتيجه التقلبات الجيوب السياسيه
حول العالم ورفع البنوك المركزيه اسعار
الفائده لمكافحه التضخم سوق التداول
السعوديه على الرغم من تحقيقه
تراجعات خلال العام لكن التراجعات كانت
اقل بكثير من نظراتها العالميه المزيد في
هذا التقرير
على الرغم من الاوضاع الجيوس السياسيه
العالميه خلال عام 2022
مخوفه من حدوث ركود عالمي غير مسبوق وهروب
رؤوس الاموال من اسواق الاسهم العالميه
بحثا عن التحول وهو ماده الى تراجعات حاده
اصابه البورصه كان الوضع مختلفا في سوق
الاسهم السعوديه
فتراجع الاسواق العالميه من شرقها الى
غربها بنسب تجاوزت 25% في الدول المتقدمه
كان له تاثير محدود على سوق تداول والتي
تراجعت بنحو سبعه في المئه فقط خلال العام
2022 وعلى عكس جفاف في سوق الطروحات
الاوليه
التي سجلت ادنى مستوى منذ اكثر من اثني
عشر سنه سجل سوق تداول 17 كتابا خلال
العام 2022 20 في السوق الرئيسيه مقابل
تسعه اكتتابات فقط في العام 2021
السوق الموازي بدوره جذب 18 كتابا في
العام 2022 مقابل 6 اكتتابات فقط في العام
جذب الاستثمارات القياسي جاء بدعم من
ارتفاع اسعار النفط عالميا والاجراءات
التشجيعيه التي اتخذتها اداره تداول
لتخفيف متطلبات الاستثمار الاجنبي
بالاضافه الى تسجيل الميزانيه السعوديه
فائضا ب 100 ومليار ريال في 2022 وهو
الاول منذ تسعه اعوام وذلك بدعم من ارتفاع
الايرادات غير النفطيه للمملكه
9.4% شال الزعيم العربيه
من الرياض يلتحق بين المختص في سوق
الاموال والاسهم انس الراجحي سيد انس مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في النشره الرابعه من
الرياض موجه من المكاسب بدايه العام مؤشر
تداول السعودي قاربت 14 نقطه ثم تذبذب حتى
وصل الى حاجز 10,000 نقطه وخساره مكاسب
2022 كيف تقيم هذا المؤشر هذا العام
نعم اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير واهلا وسهلا
بكم طبعا نحنا زي ما احنا عارفين الانخفاض
تقريبا من بدايه السنه
يعادل سبعه بالمئه وهو كما تفضلتم الادنى
انخفاض بكثير مقارنه بالاسواق العالميه
لكن لا ننسى اخي الكريم انه كثير من
الاسهم انخفضت بين 50 و70% ووزن المؤشر
تاسيس يؤثر به تقريبا 20 شركه او نحوها
يستحوذ على 90% من وزنه فقد لا يكون خلينا
نقول همم حركه المؤشر تعطي انطباع حقيقي
حول ما جرى على كثير من اسعار الاسهم التي
فقدت 50%
و70% بالمجمل احنا شفنا همم كانت في
ارتفاعات كبيره حقيقه السوق منذ ان كسر
الحاجز 6,000 و6,000 نقطه في ما يسمى
كورونا حتى وصل الى مشاعر 14,000 نقطه كان
هذا كله جاء بعد نتائج قويه جدا
انقطاع البتروكيميات وكثير من الاسهم
القياديه ممتاز نسبه الفائده كيف تغير
معها سوق الاسهم هل اثرت كذلك على شهيه
المستثمرين برايك لا شك انه اسعار الفائده
بشكل عام ترتبط بعلاقه بعلاقه عكسيه مع
اسواق المال اذا ما نظرنا الى الخيارات
والفرص البديله همم فيما يتعلق بالعائد
على الصكوك العائد على السندات العائد على
الوداع كل هذه يفضلها كثير من المستثمرين
كونها اقل مخاطر ومضمونه ومقارنه بعوائد
الاسهم التي انخفضت بسبب بعض النتائج
الماليه غير الدائمه او همم جاء بالمزامنه
مع ارتفاع همم الفائده على كثير من
الخيارات الاستثماريه الاخرى وبالتالي
شفنا هبوط على اسعار عديد من الاسهم التي
استفاده همم سوق الاسهم السعوديه من حجم
الطرحات
الاكتتابات الكبيره اللي حدث اكثر من 40
اكتتاب تقريبا حدث هذا العام
بالمناسبه الطروحات الكثيره خلينا نقول
تسحب وتجفف السيوله وتهدئ من التوخم لكن
فيما يتعلق بشكل مباشر كاس اسواق المال لا
شك انها تعطي خيارات عديده للمستثمرين
تزيد من عمق السقى السعودي فلاشف كل ما
زادت الشركات بشتى انشطتها وتواجدها في
سوق الاسهم السعوديه اعطت خيارات عديده
للمستثمرين ممتاز نشاطات التداولي همم
لماذا انخفضت بشكل مفاجئ منذ الربع الثالث
هذا العام احنا شفنا قبل يمكن ثلاثه جلسات
سجل السوق السعودي ادنا السيوله في ثلاثه
سنوات بالضبط صحيح هذه لا شك انها السيوله
متدنيه فما اسلفت اخي الكريم انه دائما
ارتفاع اسعار الفائده يجفف السيوله من
الاسواق فهذا قد يكون هو ابرز اهم سبب ادى
الى انخفاض السيوله فاتفع اسعار الفائده
يفضل الكثير المستثمرين خروج امواله
ويضعها
ياخذ عليها فوائد او البنوك او الصكوك او
سندات اضف الى ذلك انخفاض شهيه همم
المستثمرين لاخذ همم فائده اخذ تمويل
وضعها في الاسواق الماليه كونها اسعار
الفائده صارت كلتها خليني اسالك عن ادوات
الدين
برايك كيف تمت الاستفاده منها هذا العام
استاذ انس اييي بشكل عام كما اسلفت انه
ادوات الدين سواء كانت لي الحكومات او لا
الشركات كانت قد اخذت بفائده متدنيه سابقا
بعض اسعار الشركات كما ااا يعني نعلم
ارتفعت عليها التكاليف والتكاليف التمويل
بشكل كبير بعضها فضلت سدادها مبكرا اسباقا
ارتفاع اسعار الفائده فيعني حقيقه في
تباين بين الشركات وفي بعضهم من اخذ
بفائده مو همم ثابته وبعضهم بفائده متغيره
حتى فيما يتعلق بالبنوك واستفادتها بشكل
عام نيكون من ارتفاع اسعار الفائده الا
انه بعض البنوك قد يكون معظم او نصيب
النصيب الاكبر المحافظات عندهم كانت تمويل
لمحافظه الافراد وكلها بفائده ثابته
فبالتالي الاثر ما راح يكون كبير مقارنه
بمصاري اشكرك كثير شكرا من الرياض المختص
في سوق الاموال والاسهم
حياكم الله من جديد الان الى الموجز
الرياضي مع زميله ديما السائح
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك يا نايف ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا
تعاقد النصر السعودي رسميا مع البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو لموسمين ونصف وبدات
مسيرته رونالدو في سبورتينغ لشبونه لعبدها
لانديه مانشستر يونايتد وريال مدريد
ويوفنتوس قبل يعود الى مانشستر يونايتد في
ولايه الثانيه ومن ثم التوجه للعاصمه
السعوديه الرياض مع النصر وحصد رونالدو مع
البرتغال كاس اوروبا 2016 و دوري الامم
الاوروبيه 2019 كما توجا بخمسه القابل
لدوري ابطال اوروبا
في التاريخ
[موسيقى]
ونبقى مع اخبار النصر حيث يحل الفريق
ضعيفا على الخليج ضمن الجوله ال 11 من
الدوري السعودي ويسعد نادي العاصمي لتحقيق
انتصار غاب عنه في الجوله الماضيه بعد ما
اكتفى بالتعادل عالملعبه امام الهلال
ويحتل نصر المركز الثاني بث23 نقطه بينما
يملك الخليج اربع نقاط الجماعه من فوزا
وتعادل وثمان هزائم وكانت اخر مواجهه جمعت
الفريقين في دوري المحترفين في 2007
وانتهت بفوز اصفر الرياض بثلاثيه نظيفه
[موسيقى]
هو في مباراه ثانيه يعمل الهلال في
استعاده التوازنه بعد تعادله بالجوله
الماضيه عندما يستقبل ضمك في المرحله
الحادي عشر من البطوله الهلال للعوده الى
سكه الانتصارات وهو الذي يحتل المركز
الرابع برصيد 21 نقطه بينما يحتل ضمك
المركز السادس برصيد 17 ولم يوفق ضمك في
اخر ثلاث مباريات حيث تعادل امام الاتفاق
والوحده في الدوري وودع كاس الملك امام
الوحدات
ارتقى شباب الى صداره الدوري السعودي
بتغلبه على ضيفي على ضيف الاتفاق بثلاثه
اهداف دون رد ضمن الجوله ال 11 من
المسابقه الوافد الجديد سنتيمينا افتتح
التسجيل للشباب بعد مرور 20 دقيقه وقبل
نهايه الشوط الاول اضاف اياجو سانتوس
الهدف الثاني للشباب واختتم عبد الله
الخطيب ثلاثيه الشباب بهدف في مرمى فريقه
عند الدقيقه السادسه والثمانين الشباب رفع
رصده الى 25 نقطه في المركز الاول فيما
تجمد رصيد الاتفاق عند 13 نقطه
[موسيقى]
هو فاز فريق الفيحاء اعلى مضيفي الفتح
بهدفين دون رد وسجل هدفي الفيحاء انطونيو
وسعود زيدان في الشوط الثاني من المباراه
ورفع الفيحاء رصده الى 11 نقطه و توقف
رصيد الفتح عند 15 نقطه
وساده التعادل من دون اهداف مباراه الوحده
وضيفه العداله في مكه المكرمه لينا للوحده
نقطه التاسعه في ما ارتفعت حصيله العداله
الى 50 نقاط
وعلى وقع هذا الخبر نختم ونعود الان
[موسيقى]
شكرا ديمه
اذن وصلت نسبه مشاركه المراه السعوديه في
العمل ارتفاعا خلال العام 2022 حيث تجاوزت
ال 35% ياتي ذلك مع اتساع مشاركتها في
الفضاء العام نتيجه الاصلاحات التشريعيه
التي عززت من حقوقها
[موسيقى]
اذا نتحدث في هذا الجزء مشاهدينا الكرام
عن التشريعات في السعوديه الى اين وصلت في
2022 كذلك فيما يخص ايضا المراه السعوديه
نسبه المشاركه التي زادت في 2002 بالاضافه
كذلك الى مشاركتها كذلك العمل في القضاء
السعودي ويشاركني الحديث في هذه الزاويه
المحامي عبد الرحمن اللحم حياك الله
خير كبير جدا هذا العام في السعوديه اربعه
انظمه
تشريعيه وفي مقدماتها طبعا نظام الاحوال
الشخصيه والنظام الاثبات ما الذي اضافته
الى التشريعات السعوديه في 2022
اه اعتقد انه عام 2022 كان عام من تشريعي
مميزه في المملكه
وانا اسمي دا اسميه انه عام بدايه التقنين
لانه صدر فيه كما ذكرت اخوي نايف
النظامين مهمين وهي احد الانظمه الاربعه
التي اعلن عنها الامير محمد بن سلمان بن
عبد العزيز وهو نظام الاحوال الشخصيه نظام
الاثبات وهذا همم انظمه محوريه
وسدده
في السابق وفوق ذلك وقبل ذلك ان انتهت جدر
كبير تاريخي اضعنا اعمارنا فيه وهو همم
المعارضين للتقنيه الذين كانوا عطلوا
الحراك همم
التشريعي والتطور التشريعي في المملكه
طوال العقود من الزمن في تاريخ المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
هذا اصبح من التاريخ
يعني في هذه السنه من خلال هذه الانظمه
ال- ال- الاساسيه ايضا هناك انظمه اخرى لا
تقل لاهميه عنها وهي مثلا نظام الشركات
همم
خلق قوالب وافكار تشريعيه غير مسبوقه في
العالم وهذه الحركه التشريعي ليس فقط
بالكم وانما ايضا بالكيف يعني امضي معه
قوانين همم مصارعه على اسس ونظريات
قانونيه متقدمه صنعت يعني مدرسه تشجيعيه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه مستقله من
اول احنا كنا يعني
انظمه تقليديه ناخذ من الدول التي سباقات
في هذه المجال الان اذا جوت تبني عليه لا
نقول يعني حراك تشجيعيا غير خطوات تمك
المراه ابو خالد هذا العام ارتفاع نسبه
مشاركتها كذلك ايضا حتى في سوق العمل اكثر
من 35 في
المئه لكن الجديد في هذا العام هو الدخول
في الوظائف القضائيه كيف يمكن النظر اليه
طبعا
المراه هو جاء يعني في هذه السنه متميز
جدا لانه همم المراه تولد مناصب قياديه
على اعلى المستويات يعني
ثوابق تاريخيه في المملكه ايضا كما اشارت
اخوي نايف انه
المراه دخلت همم المؤسسات القرائيه ممثله
في النيابه العامه النيابه العامه هي
سباقه في هذا المجال
واتاحه للمراه ان تعمل محققه وهي وظيفه
قضائيه لاول مره في تاريخ المملكه
وتمنى انه يعني يتبعها العديد من من من من
هذه الخطوات الجريئه التي توائم مع رؤيه
الملك عندي دقيقه وارغب بالسؤال عن الحدث
الاهم هذا العام في السعوديه 2022 في ما
يخص همم سواء التشريعات او حتى ايضا
الاحداث الاجتماعيه في السعوديه
اعتقد من حيث من ناحيه من ناحيه الترشيات
كما ذكرت يعني
التشييع الاحوال الشخصيه على وجه التحديد
اعتقد انه حدث محوري ومهم جدا لانه يعالج
قضايا كبيره ولها مساس في جريحا واسعه من
المجتمع
فاول كان في تضارب بالاحكام كان يعني
ضبابيه في في
الجوارب القانونيه لكن الان انتهت هذه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر مع همم كان معنا هنا في
الاستديو طبعا المحامي عبد الرحمن شكرا
لكم انتم لكرمي ولطف المتابعه نهايه
الرابعه كل عام وانتم بخير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]